have you seen this footage of all of
these Rockets raining down onto Israel
they're calling this Israel's 911
because it totally caught them off guard
and it's one of the most ambitious
attacks in a really long time the
Rockets were fired by a group called
Hamas which refuses Israel's right to
even exist for decades Hamas has
protested Israel's occupation of
Palestinian territory by launching
missiles from this small slice of
Palestine down here called the Gaza
Strip but this attack was more deadly
than normal it's killed at least 700
Israelis most of them civilians and
thousands more wounded Israel
immediately declared war against Hamas
and the Israeli Air Force began dropping
bombs killing hundreds of Palestinian
civilians they're activating 300,000 of
their reservists to get ready to fight
they're promising that this is just the
beginning I'll be following this
conflict as it unfolds and helping you
understand it in case you want to follow
for more